if you touch our shores with your
corrupt Enterprise whether that is
through meetings or through using our
world-class financial system you will be
held accountable for that corruption
nobody is above or beyond the law these
cases require a tremendous amount of
hard work by gifted prosecutors and
investigators that hard work in our view
is worth it there's a danger that
cynicism creeps into our lives and the
folks shrug and say well that's just the
way things are that may be the way
things are but that is not the way
things have to be and one of the
important lessons of this case is that
we will not stop until we send messages
that this is not the way things should
be and that they must be different
soccer football is an egalitarian sport
it is the beautiful game because the
pitch is flat it is available to anyone
and everyone no matter where you come
from
rich or poor boy or girl you can enjoy
the beautiful game it has lifted
billions around this globe and is an
incredibly popular and fast-growing
sport here in the United States the game
according to the allegations in this
indictment was hijacked that field that
is so famously flat was made tilted in
favor of those who are looking to gain
at the expense of countries and kids who
were enjoying the game of soccer
this hijacking is being met with a very
aggressive prosecutorial response in
order to change behavior as the US
Attorney said this investigation has
been long and painstaking and it is not
over and the work will continue until
all of the corruption is uncovered and a
message is sent around the world that
this conduct will not be tolerated a